nos encontramos en la población de
mykolaiv donde esta mañana han vuelto a
darse ataques especialmente contra áreas
habitadas por la población civil esta
población se ha convertido en
estratégica en la lucha para la toma de
oleza que es la ciudad más importante
sobre el mar negro
aquí hubo uno de los ataques más duros
que se ha dado durante estas ya casi
cuatro semanas de guerra sucedió en la
madrugada de ayer contra una base
militar
donde dormían al menos 200 marines se
habla de que 40 personas murieron aunque
hablando con los habitantes de esta
población creen incluso que habrían
muerto el doble o incluso el triple y
también se habla de civiles que habrían
llegado también y dos y muertos al
hospital como no lo contaba uno de los
trabajadores esta mañana que no quiso
dar su nombre hemos estado intentando
entrar a la base durante el día pero se
ha negado el acceso a los medios de
comunicación como también se negó el
acceso a la morgue donde sí vimos como
entraban un contenedor frigorífico en el
que seguramente iban a introducir estos
cadáveres que no solamente son aquellos
de los ataques de las últimas horas sino
que cuando habíamos visitado este lugar
durante la semana ya habíamos visto
bastantes cadáveres de militares
depositados en este lugar está hoy
también el portavoz del ministerio de
defensa ruso dijo que había lanzado
varios misiles ultrasónicos a una
población no lejana de aquí a 20
kilómetros sin embargo no se ven ningún
viso de estas paradas que tendrían que
llegar porque esto era una base donde se
guardaban combustible sin embargo
estamos a la espera de la confirmación
que hagan las fuerzas ucranianas